هذا ليس مجرد غداء ، إنه إطلاق من
النوع الذي يتم إطلاقه في الفضاء ،
ربما هذا الكباب الحار من
مطعم في جنوب تركيا لم
يجذب حشودًا مبتهجة ،
لكنه حصل على عد تنازلي حيث
قام مطعم kabugachi yashar بتوقيت
إطلاق الكباب للاحتفال  الذكرى الحادية والستين
لأول
رائد فضاء روسي يدور حول الأرض ، وعلى الرغم من أن
الزينة النباتية سقطت على الفور ، إلا أن
الكباب قد تم رفعه نحو السماء بواسطة
بالون من الهيليوم ينضم إلى أجسام غريبة أخرى تم
إطلاقها أيضًا بدءًا من
الجعة إلى bobblehead obama
buzz lightyear
الفضاء من خلال ربط الركوب وتفريغ Spacex من
حمولة تسلا لا تزال
تطفو هناك
ولكن ليس من السهل التسلق على ارتفاع 62 ميلاً على الأقل
فوق الأرض إلى حيث
يتم رسم الحدود مع الفضاء في كثير من الأحيان ،
جعل الكباب فقط حوالي 25
ميلاً قبل أن ينفجر البالون الخاص به.
قام صاحب المطعم بتتبع الكباب باستخدام
نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) إلى حيث تناثر في البحر على
بعد 75 ميلاً من موقع الإطلاق الذي
كان عليه  من السهل استرجاع الكباب ، ربما
كان مشبعًا بالمياه لدرجة أنه لا يخدم رواد المطعم ، لكن
تم الاحتفال بعودته كما لو كان قد
هبط على سطح القمر ،
وهو ما يجعله
أكثر جني
الكباب في نيويورك.